You
Why hello there my cats are being very active right now hello hello we are so
Live what wondrous adventure awaits us today who knows oh no I have to sneeze
Okay
We did we out here
How are you guys doing? I hope you had a good day yesterday. I hope you enjoyed
I know for those who are able to catch it the DSMR. Yeah now now be fun
I know what I've never done. I need to add
My BGM to my chatting screen. That's what I should know
So, you don't hear me just gap and silence into my AC
There we go oh
Yeah, no, definitely I have another
ASMR next week and we're gonna focus on
some particular
Scenario
Dude, dude, dude, dude. Oh god, I'm
Thank God you guys didn't hear it, but I was like, why do I hear myself? It's because my
Stream was playing in my headphones. I'm very tired. I don't know why I'm so tired am I hungover who knows I
Didn't sleep last night, I guess well, it feels like I like closed my eyes and I blinked and I was awake and
And then um and it was 10 30 a.m. And I'm like, oh I had a
therapist appointment
Yeah, somebody got me I can't open air from throne so thank you
I
Suggested it like you need this what's creepy though
It's that it's the same brand as my pots and pans that I use and the same color so it matches
Well, I didn't black out. No, it was not that bad not at all. It's more so like I got distracted. I
Was fucking about you know as one does on the interwebs scrolling through a tweet are
Intique of the talk as the kids say and I'm just like, oh wait
It's almost 2 a.m. Silly me. I should probably sleep
You didn't say you were like oh, I'm not that light and one and a half drinks does not put me black out
I'm not that that bad
It's good to see my neck is in one piece. It is indeed attached to my body
Oh, no, I'm fine. Yeah, I uh
so
I'm sorry. I have to admit something I
Lied to you
It actually did I didn't notice until this morning, but it did cut my finger. I just never noticed I can
But it's fine
Just it's like it was a little little skin
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. I think I'm getting sick though. I
Think when I went grocery shopping yesterday morning at the store, there was like a bunch of sick people because now
I'm feeling a bit ill
I'm feeling a wee bit ill. I got some tea
Made it in my new teapot
Thank God because I was tired of microwaving my tea
And I know my British fans out there would be horrified to hear that I microwaved my tea
It's just easy to just throw it in there for like a minute 30 and I'm good
But now I have a nice tea kettle
So I've made myself some nice chamomile tea
I didn't hear you just say that
What
What uh, you don't you don't like microwave water microwave water is delicious
It's chamomile tea. I like I don't know why I'm drinking it
But it's like my favorite tea because it might make me sleepy
It's like a lavender chamomile like it's called sleepy time tea has a little cozy bear and he's you know
He's hanging out you buy the fire getting all epee
We're gonna be cozy top-ten anime betrayals. Oh
No, the thing didn't play I
Need to keep my desktop audio on because it says I'll do with the voice line. Thank you for the the don't know by the way friend
The don't know usually sco's oh
for me I
Did some I was messing around I was like, oh, let me take a nap. No, I did not take a nap
I was messing around with alerts and I am
Was I added voice lines for all like the tip
Options so they're good. Some of them are goofy. Some of them are like, ooh
But most of them are goofy because you know, I'm goofy. I
Don't know why I'm leaning so much. I got that that gangster lean. Hold on. Let me just eat. There we go
I wasn't like quite upright whoopsie
Hey, I'm southern we here we drink our tea iced and sugared to heck hell. Yeah, that's how it should be brother. I
Love me some iced tea some sweet tea
Outside she's dumb but inside she's goofy
Was something triggering said I miss yeah that I microwaved my tea
She microwaves her tea
Someone has to tell the king or the queen or the other mothers of the royal family. I don't know
Tea with rum. No, although I do have this bottle of whiskey
Honey, Tennessee whiskey. Oh, what? Oh
Hello straw knee and friends straw knee and brieflings. Hello
How are you doing Japanese tea is good. I saw that we were playing eddie streamer overdose. I love that game so much
I'm just music is so good
Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Stronger raid. Unless it's stoner raid and I'm like, oh, all right
How was it how will be no, I know mummy has been streaming for like
12 hour streams the past two days. So please get some rest my dear
Let me attend out of ten of nowhere. I didn't expect it. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yes. I love that
Yeah, it's such a good game. I remember when I first played it. I'm like
Somebody had made a comment. I think on the steam page
Like is this a psychological horror game or is this cute and I'm like hold on
Is this doki-doki literature club type beat? So I played it and I was like, oh, no, she overdoses
So, yeah, it's a great it's a great game. It's really really interesting
Just how you can manipulate like an online talent as her like manager
Very very interesting
And it's like just brings a whole new perspective to like how men head up
Women can be
Um overdosing did oh doki-doki literature club is literally one of my favorite games of all time
That would be super fought you hope it would do Texas Beach
I thought it I thought I had it do the Texas Beach. Maybe I have to might have to go in and fix that
But yeah
Anyways, what what ASMR audio what was I supposed to do ASMR audio?
kidding oh
I was like
Was there another I'm it was there a script that I missed. I'm like I recorded like three months
No, sorry, she's she's not even a manager. She'll just be like she was sliding to my DM. She'll be like hey
I'm like hey. She's like can you like
Mone into this mic for me real quick and I'm like bet oh and then she's like perfect and then she's like
Skuttles
Just no context just I'm like all right
Then it just pops up later in some random thing
My file now yoink
She I'm pretty sure she has probably like in a sound archive of just a bunch of random noises of me of me and all
The other girls just like hey, can you laugh like this? Oh, can you make this noise? Oh, can you like burp?
Can you sneeze? It's just so she can just throw stuff together
um
strong
You know what strong you should do she should just run our voices through an AI
Just oh, I need I need so and so to do this and then she's like types it in the generator now
Just like if we're not around her for a sleep. I believe you replace the AI. Oh god. I hope not
Oh
although an AI an AI whore, I mean woman of the night
That'd be pretty hard
Neurosama after hours
Can we can we get up by by strudy can we get up wait try before I go can we can we get a AI?
Robo waifu next jet. I'm just throwing like guys like so
Strongies are creative director
And so I just like will randomly slide in her DMs and be like hey, so for gen 2
slime girl
dog girl
Robo waifu
monster
ogre lady
It's just because
Oh
But just it's so fun having like gen mates that like have the same taste as you and even if they don't have the same taste
You're just like oh, okay. I see where you're coming from. That's that's a pretty good idea. Okay, very cultured
Yeah, yeah, platypus girl. She can lay eggs, but then give me
No
Dress up as there as a platypus
Although did you am I allowed to talk about like my spicy all or like other girls spicy? Oh, I don't know
I will figure it out
But is there I made some beautiful art on her all so good. I hope she finishes it a wombat girl
I like to call rain on a wombat and
Did you know that like
I'm like that
Should I be saying this that breast milk tastes very sweet
One of my
friends had a baby
Recently and she's like she be and I'm like, yeah, she's like
You keep looking at the baby's bottle
Do you want a taste and I'm like straight from the source and she's like we were just we were joking
We were joking. She's like here and she's just like put some out like in a little like shot glass for me
so I did
My friends breast milk and I'm just like
Wow that is surprisingly good
Well then like it makes sense because it has all this like nourishment and all this like whatever stuff
And I'm like that's some that's some good stuff right there. So if Azura ever made like a
Like a milk based
Like merch item like she starts selling her own like blue milk like and it's
Azura do lay
This is like I
Wouldn't be a verse to try again 100%
Um
She be you've been streaming for five days and you've tased chat
You've talked about drinking breast milk. You don't many suspicious things on stream if anyone's getting like
Demonetized or their channel terminated first. It's probably gonna be me
I
Sir impression is so good. Yeah, she has like a really
Sing song II dragged out
like voice
It's like she's thinking but then she also kind of has like a valet girl accent at the same
It's really like she'll be like, oh my no, she doesn't say oh my gosh at all. I don't know
I
Take you to management to the dungeon. Yeah, nah, and we would win
Oh, I can one up that I can one up in all of that. Should I be wanting up in me?
So one time
In another era of she be I was streaming some lovely games with my with one of my friends
Toma you might know Toma keys and um, we were playing. I know we were doing
We were doing smash your pass on Pokemon
And um
So I I had eaten something. I think like I got like food poisoning. So I'm sitting there
I'm like, oh my god, like I really have to use the bathroom like if I fart like it's not gonna be good
Um
So I'm sitting and we're laughing and I'm about to be like, oh, let me I'm just gonna be or be real quick to run to
The bathroom and then we get a raid of like four hundred people
And I'm like, oh
Hi everyone, welcome to the stream
Oh, we're just we're just talking about Pokemon and I'm like trying so hard not to fart
And then I'm like, I'm sad as I said the guys guys you don't even I sat there for like 10 minutes
fighting for my life
Waiting for like I just wanted people to leave at that point like though
Because like I being a small stripper I was like, oh, I need to keep up the momentum
I need to I can't just like leave when they rate some is like, oh, you know what I
Will shit myself right now
Maintain the numbers
Like oh, yes, let me continue to talk about how I would smash how I wouldn't smash any bird Pokemon because it's a fucking
But no, it was fine, I didn't you know, I can't one up in me because I didn't actually shit myself but afterwards I
Did like
Low-pony can get it. Um, I
Did fight for my life on the bathroom
Sorry for the TMI, but you know as I mentioned I had a therapist point this appointment this morning
And I was like talking about you guys so
Like I said, I'm at all it's serious. So
You know
We had like you thought you were being parasol. No, I'm already talking to my therapist about you
It was like, oh my god
And it was great and like I had to send my therapist a bunch of stuff about vTubers just cuz she doesn't know what they are
It's moving too quickly. No, it's not moving fast enough
and
She's like, oh my gosh, I'm so proud of you because she knows I've been working towards being like a full-time streamer
No, you're not the abuse abuse of boyfriend. You're the sweetest you the sweetest little subby boyfriend a girl could ask for
Um
But so I told her so she she doesn't know like the full extent of like the content I make
Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised if she was watching me right now
Hi, Cheryl
But
She uh, I told her like
So I told her that my outfit is risque cuz she's like, oh, I told her that I got merch merch plug. Ooh market
And she's like, oh, I want to buy your merch and I'm like, I I don't think you should
Because I don't think I want and she's like this really sweet older woman. She's like
Middle-aged and she's she's like, let me support you
I don't like I feel like that's a breach of stuff, but I don't like she's been with me for years
so but I'm like
You should probably get a key chain
It not the shirt cuz she's like, I want a shirt. I'm like, I don't think you want a bondage bunny on a shirt
Yeah, I don't want some rude ain't wearing outside, you know what I don't even your support is all them like that's just
You don't have to wear it out. That's okay. If you rep me
honestly
Hell to the yeah, I don't even think I can wear my own merch outside because I just
Something deep down just tells me I'd be identified if I'm wearing my merch and then I like go to like
CVS or something and then I'm like, hey, I'd like to get like
Some a pack of gum and they're just like
She be caught in by like I just feel like I would be
Noticed it's happened before I've had
When I was a flesh tuber someone I was working at my normal day job and someone's just like are you?
redacted and I'm like
No
They're just like wow you look exactly like her and I'm like wow, that's crazy
Anyways, did you want to buy anything else?
That's something that happened at the target
Yeah
And like even like I'm nervous to like say like oh I went to this place today because I'm like there is somebody out
There that will figure out exactly what store I'm at and be like triangulate my location
And then they'll see me be like oh my god, she's a rat and I'll be like
Yeah, I'm you I'm you oh she right
Redacted as my favorite streamer. Oh, yeah, I was a lot more based back then and politically incorrect
That's for sure being a former commentary youtuber
Immersion broken redacted is that honestly that would be a cool name for a streamer. Hey, what's up? I'm redacted. He just called her Daki. Oh
I got gen 2 a vtuber that's just covered in sensor bars and her name is redacted
Her outfit is made out of sensor bars
You had flesh. No never flesh
You know Daki Daki
Right, that's not a bad idea. She's like she's like a what's it called?
one of those exhibitionists
Yo, I'm cooking I'm cooking feeler gen 2 redacted although we were making jokes that
V2 could be feeler gen 2 could be like V sucky. No, that'd be so are like suck you
That'd be so bad
New creative dry little shawty. I'm taking your spot. Let me take a sip of tea. Oh
Did it go did you guys hear that?
Did you guys hear the donut? Thank you for the donut by the way, did you guys hear it?
Nope, okay, so I'll say so it's when you do
$6.90 it goes take me out to dinner sometime won't you like
That's what it does mix your tea with alcohol. No, I'm not mixing my tea with alcohol. Why would you want me to do that?
Okay, let me see if I turn it all the way up. I feel a little continue to do it
I don't know man ouch smack my hand on something am I hungover. I don't think I am I just don't think I slept well
It's Trinay. Yeah, she possesses me sometimes. I am I am her her clone. So just an Americanized version
Ducky is just solid black giant sensor bar the ultimate. Oh, but like drow drow skin tone
She's like dark Alfie
Dude, I'm cooking. I wish I'd like artistic ability like Emmy because oh my god
I'd be like, let's forget mr. Hopps. We're drawing
Choco bros be good
Give me I was like a pop
But um commission Emmy for the art all hundred percent hundred percent
I'm like I'm already think trying to think I'm like how what can I commission Emmy for she's so talented
I
Ten out of ten, thank you
Some of you are cultured. You know what it's funny though. I saw some people be like, oh, can you not?
Why do they burp in your streams? It's so un-lady like I'm not a lady
What whatever made you think that I'm some sort of lady
I'm not I'm not a good young lady. I'm a fucking who oh
That work
The ten dollars I didn't do anything for ten dollars that wait. No, I think it was it's like, oh, thank you, sweetheart
Did you hear that it worked? You almost heard it
Someone okay, I'm gonna go turn them up then because for me when I was listening to them back
It was like super loud. So I put it at like 30%
Thank you for the dono names
Oh my god, are you she weak wait, this is from Barrow. Oh my god, are you she be condom my grandma loves your streams?
Where's your merch the rabbit?
And I it's also supposed to do text-to-speech, man
I I'm not joking when I say I literally fucking hate stream elements
I'm sorry
Oh, it's so confusing
Oh
No fuck
Please let me change the settings for the tips. I beg of you. Oh, okay, let's turn it up to 50
Lovely
Variations because yeah, I have one for 15 25
$6.09
420 like $4.26 like the things that are on my machine elements. So and then there's also a secret one
I
Do do do let me turn these all up though
My poor babies can't hear my beautiful mommy voice
But yeah, cuz my manager was explained like in straw knee we're like cuz I was like straw knee
How did you do all your alerts so my manager was helping me yesterday set up
The alerts and then I was recording stuff this morning because I thought it would just be funny cuz straw knee was like
Oh, yeah, you can do like variations and I was like, what?
Okay, you couldn't do that on stream labs. So I'm like word. Let's do it. Okay. Oh
I wonder if you guys can hear me AC
Oh
A giant ass be just flew into the window that just scared me
Yeah, so for like the first half of stream I always like to like not play a game or
Just like fuck around with my settings for an hour. That's you know, that's that's really professional, isn't it?
Yes, it's coming
Be for gen 2. I think I don't Yen's getting a bee. I'm excited for their next gen
Um, I am someone who I just love I love watching debuts. I love watching debuts
um
I watched all the pixel ink girls. They were really sweet
You may plus girls. Oh, well, yeah, like anybody that's like debuted recently
That's in an agency. I've watched and even some indies. It's just fun
Like I like getting to know people. I just I just sit quietly in the chat though. I don't say anything cuz I'm too shy
Yeah, I watched like um
Like before Mariah's debuts. Oh, those were so good. Like there's so many talented people in the community
So
Sorry
Mmm, yeah, like there's just like a lot of cool. Like I watched like mono and um
and alias and
Nova and stuff they're like the v4 mariah girls so creative and so where the in the pixel like girls
I always go for like comfy. Like I'm like, okay. Let me watch like, um
Like uh, chio or I'll watch, um
Me and uh, I can never pronounce anybody's names though. Um
Erlotte
But yeah talented talented yappers. Yes
Did you watch for the debuts for this new company called velar? Nah
Mean valier. Nah
No, yeah, I technically I watched our debuts like three times
Because we had to do we did some um test runs
Japanese
You're doing a summer art mind. Oh, yeah, go ahead. Thank you. I mean visaki. Yeah, then, you know, you mean visaki
You mean visaki
Okay, let's see
I think that's good
All the debuts stuff went so smoothly a test run. Oh, yeah. No, I really did it really did we prepared really hard
Um, it was really fun though. Just like the first time we did a test run
So we were like, okay, we'll meet for like three hours to be like to you know, the normal length of our debuts
We were probably together the entire day
I don't know if it was like
Five or six or seven hours because we were hysterically laughing at each other because we were just having so much fun
And then there'll be like technical issues
And so like we would all be in a discord call while we watch one of the girls like stream on a like a unlisted thing
And we just be like I remember
Like so azura's model has like really good eye tracking for some reason and so you can really see when she goes like
When she like shifts her eyes
So when she was looking at like um, like her talking points, she would just let be like
Anyways, and then like you thought so we were just die laughing every time she looked at her talking points
And like you could see it like um in our uh, our two point our no our debut collab where she's like kind of like shifty
Eye looking at at icy
It was so funny
If you sucky debuts are okay except this weird bunny girl, I know right
You like the cotton mog girl. Nah, she was my least favorite. She's my least favorite
You know the eye tracking is good. We all have iPhones for eye tracking
Uh eye tracking with oh my god, there's kids running down the hallway behind me and that just scared me because they're like
iPhones are very good for their facial tracking. Um, I would
Like and also it's uh, it's also dependent on the rigor like a really good rigor
um can
Even if you like have a webcam
And it could almost make it seem like you're using vbridger because the tracking is just so good
So although I I don't have my
My model my phone plugged into my computer right now. So I'm going off at wi-fi. So I know my mouth tracking is like
You have samsung phone
How's how is it when you ruin group chats?
You love my hair drills. Yeah, I love my hair drills too because my hair is curly
I love curly hair
um, but
I can't draw my own hair though
It's hard to draw my own ringlets. It just looks like weird spaghetti
Hair arms for your next outfit. Yeah, I'll just be like one of the the arms characters
You love her side. I know is there a side eye is the best
As much as I just like apple their cameras are tracking are goaded, you know, it's not even like apples
cameras because samsung's cameras have a way higher
Like mega pixel amount. It's just like apple has this really good
Software for their cameras and I'm like if you married the two of like a samsung camera camera
And apple software or like android camera and apple software, then yeah, I am I am an apple fan
Um, just because just ease of their ecosystem, but like I do still like android
I just
For like modding everything, but they just have a terrible user interface
One of my friends is an android and I'll be on her phone and I'll be like she'll be like, oh, can you like
respond to this text for me? And I'm like, yeah, and I'm like
Okay, so how do I go to the homepage?
How do I do this to broke for apple stuff on apple stuff is so freaking expensive. It's
ridiculous
I save I save a save like I because I didn't like they didn't I think they bought phones for the other girls
But I already had a phone. I saved for a very long time
to and I got
I got a 15 coming from a
something or other
xr
Whatever
Although they also like
they just
I'm not I'm not gonna go rant about apple right now. I'm just like let's just talk about tech and glomerates
Incorporations and greed
You mean how do I go that I know everything it's when you're used to something like maneuvering around
I'm just it's it's hard to like switch and go to the next one because like
I have a mac that I used for school and stuff and I do my my assignments on
And then but then I stream on a pc and like do everything games on a pc
so it's like
And so
It's annoying on a mac because it like everything scrolls in the opposite direction
So like I'll be on my pc and I would like have to like hop on my my mac book and then I'd be like, oh frick
How do I work this thing again?
Cancel the game we need to deconstruct capitalism. Well, you guys know the vibes I talk for like a yap for a bit
And then we get into the game
Apart from adding another camera every year we haven't I know
Yes, that's so true
Like it is it's frustrating for me because I was just like do I even I'm wondering what the 16 will look like like
I'm a huge tech head. I'm not gonna lie. Like I like to watch like the keynotes and wwdc and all that stuff
Um, just to see what's up and like how things are progressing like I like to see how um
Watch I'm gonna call it just like how apple will tackle
You know machine learning and AI and all that jazz just because like other like google's already on top of that
So it's just really fun. Like I like watching marcus brownlee and just his uh,
um breakdowns of stuff and also like other uh youtubers, uh
Tear downs I was like care downs. That's not it. They're not caring for the device that they're destroying
We yapp we game and yapp and the game and yapp the circle of yapp the circle
I know he I just like watching to um marcus brownlee. Why are you so cool? I'm not
I'm not cool
You just think I'm cool because we have similar interests stop it
Yeah
I'm a yabbit
Yes, I'm very much a yabbit
I worked for apple once they actually treated every employee very good in the work life balance pretty great as well
But overpriced his understanding. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Um, I had a friend who worked for apple as well
They said that it was good. Um, because they like what the heck they got like good benefits and stuff
And they like they paid well. So of course like and like retail is um, because they're like or whatever
The retail stores or whatever or their customer service calls
Like um could be pretty tough, but if like that if you have that and that's that's pretty good like
It's good that they treat their employees. Well, although I know like a lot of
um
tech companies right now are like laying off a lot of people because of everything during coveted
So I hope it doesn't seem like apple has been hit with that because I know google's had a lot of layoffs
Layoffs and it's because of like I for my what I went to school for although I I'll be honest with you
I didn't finish school
Because one I am a very indecisive person for my major
um, but I
So I was going to major in creative writing and then I changed it and then I was going to major in veterinary science
And then I changed it and then I was going to major in english because then I changed it
And then I was going to major in biology and then I changed it
And then I was going to major in um
Uh cyber security and then I changed it and then I was going to do it and then I changed it
And then I finally settled on
Software engineering and then I never finished
My parents are not happy with me
Oh, yeah, and I almost went to art school
How many years oh no, it was only like it was over the course of like three years no biggie
it's like
like I could go back and finish my software engineering degree, but
like I'm like
Like I was still in school when I start like a like a couple months ago, but
I'll be honest. I wanted to focus on streaming
And I know that's probably not the best thing to do, but I was
I was just super passionate about fulfilling because I've had dreams of being a content creator. Um since I was a
Since when I was
I don't know how old was I a wee child
In my parents like laughed at me and stuff
I remember when I was I used to uh, I was a nice flush tube and uh twitch
My mom's like you're gonna get abducted
I saw someone say before it was it was yeeted by a mod you failed art school. No, I didn't fail art school
I never went to art school. I though I did want to major in illustration
Um, but I didn't end up going to art school
I want to be with my friends when I should have gone to like a vocational school
For because I almost went for like a vocational school for um veterinary medicine, but yeah, my mom was is very uh
Not happy with me
But when I'm like mom look, I'm streaming. She's but like, you know, my parents
They're very supportive of me now because um, I they saw my determination
um
And my motivation and like, you know, like I still have a day job
Um, and I was still going to school while I was streaming but now
Since I have VLR. I was like, you know what? Let me put a pause on that
You have like I have so much time in the world to finish school, you know
Yeah, you can't you can always go back to school
You can't join a VTB agency every day a hundred percent. Um
and
Yeah, then I can save and pay off my school debt that I have accumulated
A day job for now. Yeah, like again, I've said it multiple times if I can stream full time that'd be cool
like uh, so
I do want to yeah, I've already said this before as well. Um the first two weeks
of
After debut, I am pretty much streaming every day, but it's going to change because I have to go back to my day job
Um, so it'll be I'll be honest with you. My stream times may change and be inconsistent. I'll still stream like
maybe
Like five. Yeah, at least five times a week in like two days off. Um
It do me
But uh, please don't mind me if school debt it hurts
Yeah, do it makes you happy. This brings me joy. This brings me happiness
Um
And obviously like you need to be realistic and stuff when it like comes to money and like getting a degree and everything
But honestly, it feels like a degree meant something 10 years ago. And now it doesn't anymore
See like I'm trying to like minimize my burps if you guys are gonna rate me so low. I'm going to go harder with my burps
Ever try to cover your burp with a fart
And I've tried to cover my fart with a burp
Yeah
Done in time and so I choose to draw my own type nice nice
Sometimes I felt like I feel like it never meant anything. Well, like school. Yeah to the degree
That's what I hear
Like my parents didn't go to school like my dad never finished college and neither did my mom and then they're but they're very
Like my mom if she did go to school
She would be running like a fortune 500 company right now like 100. She's such a smart ambitious woman if you want like, you know like like
Uh minus like the dying of some unknown disease
My mom really reminds me of queen just like and not she didn't
Teach me to be a woman of the night
But like she's just like this entrepreneurial like really smart like
Bad-ass woman and she always wears
Work outfits just more appropriately appropriately clothed instead of myself
So because like I remember I showed her my model
And she's in the lore and everything and she's like, oh my gosh, this reminds me of me. I'm like mom
And I didn't show it to my dad. I just I just showed the neck up to my dad because my dad would be like you harlot
But mommy, sorry mom, uh woman of the night sounds like a Batman rip off
But um
No, yeah, like I just I just wanted to do stuff that makes me happy and yapping makes me happy
Um, yeah, I can always go back to school. Um
I could finish I probably have like two more years left of of school
but
Excuse your lateness. No terrible somebody flog him mods flog him. I have to fart now though
She's just like me for real for real. She'd be small. Yeah, just like it's more so like oh office woman
That kind of gets like gypped for a lot of things
Um, I didn't know I could have that sort of power thank god that's this that's too that's too funny actually
Oh, that's
You don't know what you've created
She
Maybe she had a chapter in her life, you don't know about I highly doubt that my mom is not like that at all
I'm in danger
Mother merciless
Tactical
Um
But yeah, I just can't wait to see where we'll go in the next like year or so year two or three or four or five or six
You're never getting rid of me
I'm never leaving you're stuck with me now. I hope you know that
Um, sorry that was a yondery moment. It was so weird sometimes it just happens
Okay
Good mercy impression
Shall we play a game?
Oh don't look at my desktop though
I
It's just my tits
So yeah, you see like you know how that was just right now
um, so when
Some of you guys know the story the other day. In fact, I'm gonna stick myself down here. Um, just so my boobies aren't
You're gonna get big headed
She be so
You know how I mentioned like those maintenance guys came in I had my headphones on they knocked on the door
Um, I didn't hear them
So they just let themselves in thinking I wasn't home to do some like just change my filters and check my water and stuff
so I just have
That
In the background just like I have me just around and then I have like that
I
Don't miss like oh, yeah
And then just like toys everywhere
My crop is on my desk. It was great. It was really you know, we bonded that day
I have uh display capture on um, oops
I have display capture on because um, what's it called?
uh
Hops mr. House hops play house my uncle's house. Um, doesn't my creepy a strange uncle's house doesn't
Won't work with the game capture for some reason or window capture
So let me set that up
Do we do we do I like how there's just two of me
Yeah, I'm gonna move move myself to the side
I
Four hands two heads double the sheebie for double the dom
We have the domi-mommies too and we will have our way with you
I feel like I have to pee
Oh my headphones are dying what
I literally charge these overnight
Like how I duck and I'm just like hmm
Yeah, I need to get a cover-ups on my booba for monetization
We discovered so that's why I'm down here. Although for the first hour I am just titties. So I should have
Probably thought that through
But like I rarely even remember that they're there. I'm just I just look at my beautiful face
Is she's making me
Prepare for trouble make it double. Let's see how loud this is
I hate that my your chat the chat goes like off of the bubble but because it's a bubble I can't make it fit properly
Oh
That is loud as hell
I am so sorry
It was also loud as fuck in my headphones as well
Hold on hold on hold on we gotta we gotta get the ambiance with this hold on a moment
He he he he
Oh, I didn't mean to press that I meant to press this
Oh
He he he he
Oh, yeah, there we go
Are you ready
Are you feeling spoopy
I don't know what the yellow bar is. I think that's just like part of the thing
Let me see if I can get rid of it
I can't get rid of it
What the frick and we'll let me get rid of it what the hey
It's not even obs because it's showing on my screen on the game
E
Oh, there you go here. I'll just move it to the side so you can't notice it as much
You
Perfect fuck hold on
Perfect fuck it's still there
Perfect I know you can't hear the game. It's because I'm not on the window you goobers
Now you can because I'm back on the window goobers
Scuff madam. I've always been scuffed, you know, but that's that's the sweet stuff
People are like she be girl failure. Well, you know what?
You asked for it and you got it girl failure she be
Is here for you
So
Open your mouth and pretend you're my loo
I almost took your mountain
I think this game is like british
Why girl failure are you a man? Um, totally
You see have you seen this I must be a weird-looking man then
I
Must taste like tea. Oh my god
What's terrifying thing of all british people? Oh
You want a bottle of water?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I could be I could be hold on let me do my best like cringy
Hey, baby girl you want
You want to come ride this pony
You can't see I'm biting my lip
Are you are you rizzing yourself? Hmm. I'm biting my lip again. Just so just just pretend
Hey mama
You got a boyfriend
Oh you do what your man won't let you have friends, baby girl
Are you feeling rizzed are you rizzed my female my female viewers do you feel rizzed right now?
Seems like more toggles are I need a lip biting toggle management. I need a lip
Oh
Wait, I can use a controller with this
Okay, I'm using a controller with this then
Because that would be so much fucking easier for me
Cringe toggle this is my cringe toggle. Oh wait, it takes a screenshot though
Oh
Wait, I did not was not reading hold on did anybody get any of that
That's a creepy-ass bunny. Oh, he's gone mom dad
Okay, whoo, sorry I'm pressing buttons
Interesting this is such a weird controls
As a fan viewer sure totally rizz
Click that's going in my cringe compilation
Excalibur first tell toggle from like um from uh soul leader that would be so funny. All right. Oh
Did I just fucking die from stepping on a bear, okay
All right
How do I how do I interact with this? Okay, it's circle mom jenna me ruby dad david
Oh my god, is she like me her dad's brown
Oh
Footsteps are allowed make sure it's safe before co- what do you mean?
What do you mean root? What do you mean ruby is evil scrumptly shadow demon
Can I go this way oh
Uh
Why do I just leave all my fucking toys around why do we have a statue in our house?
Yeah
This is gonna be an easy game for me come on, I'm a little too dark. Let me just you
I was looking like an unlockable character for a second
Why is this house so big million?
I'm going downstairs. I can't go downstairs. I'm going inside
Oh mom dad, where are you mom dad? Where are you?
Go back to bed. Yeah, but
Okay
Am I not gonna say anything about that on the wall?
All right, well, uh, can I run and jump?
I pressed the wrong button
It's too quiet, I'm scared you can run with right trigger
You
That's not correct
The fuck I won't let me
I can't run hold on I'm I just no fuck whatever
Oh
It's fine
Mr. Hop
Oh
Okay, I'm upstairs why am I upstairs? Why can I also crouch I don't can I open it? Oh
Oh, he's
Objective survive where is he can I set off a toy that'll go after
I
Am terrified I am scared I I cannot do this
How am I is he's just circling
Okay, I'm going for it
How did he get up here
I
Run run bitch run
Where is he okay, he's far away. Yeah, no, he's not
What
What the fuck I'm afraid he's gonna like walk out of the hallway. Why are there so many hallways in this house?
He looks like a rabbit
Oh, this is my room. Oh shit. Okay. Um, what's that?
I can just
Go back to sleep
All right guys, uh, thanks for coming to my playthrough of
Yeah, I'm pretty talented, uh, I'm just a gamer, you know
I
Okay, so I just gotta leave
Oh fuck my worst enemy is this
Oh
Sweet baby Jesus, I hate the train she'd be more like she be gaming. Oh my god facts
Yeah
Okay, that was my parents room. Can I go downstairs? Okay, I can
Son of knife
Oh
It's a guitar I thought I could pick it up
Oh well
I
Can I call call for help
Why I was behind the couch
That doesn't make any sense
I was behind the house
This is a bunny mating call. Fuck it. Fuck it. Fuck it. Run. Run bitch. Run
Oh, can actually can I go back in here? No, I can't I don't think I can
Oh, I almost ran for it too
I
This house has too many entry ways
Oh
Yeah, no, okay
I'm so mad. I just can't run. I can just run like a pathetic little british child. I'm just a victorian child
I can hear him far away
And I can hear when he gets closer
Okay, he's probably gonna cross over now. Okay. No, he's
Oof
Okay, so he's then he's gonna come forward
He can hear my footsteps. I forgot that he can hear my footsteps as well
It's not letting me interact with this
Oh
Oh, fuck
I would I would suck at five nights at Freddy's I I know I suck because I I played it and I was trash. Yeah
Yeah
Okay time to go
Oh
What mom I don't I don't need to look for my mom. She's fine. I'm a child. Oh
That music is so fucking annoying
It's both of you
Hey, he's he's just freaking oh
He's real fast with it and I'm real clumsy so
Can I just can I just go can I just
Damn, I feel like that's the key to leave and I'm just like bye mom
I mean you're in-game mom
Yeah, let me just go call my mom right now. I'll be like, hey mom. Are you trapped in a game?
Okay
Why is it so fucking quiet
With
Am I in the basement? Oh my god
Ow, I hurt my shoulder
I have to fight what is this fucking slender man
I
Don't why did I pick this game?
I'm like, oh, let me get a bunny themed game. Oh, I like horror
I like watching it. I hate playing. Actually, no, I do like playing horror games
She beat dear I'm in a game and the chat is a bunch of lewd people wanting me to step on them help me
Slender man crossover. I know he's gonna pop out again
I
May fart in fear
Okay, all right, what?
18th of april that's already passed. I wonder what happens when you play this game on that day probably nothing
Okay, can I keep going this way? Oh
I
Getting closer
What is the battery at the bottom for
Is that my run because I'm that I must be able to run
Wait
How do I go back to the top floor
Oh frick wait, I think I just go straight. It doesn't really give you like many indicators
Right am I stupid?
Where's the wrong button I will figure this out
I double tap
And she was more like a beauty king from over you see
I
I'm already lost. Oh no go back. No go back
Behind one of those doors it was only that door
This is that's that door. How do I go back?
I
That way this way
That way that way that way we live on this floor now
Do I just go straight past might the door?
Never thought I would watch a stream of a bondage bunny playing a horror game while humming michael jackson's billy gene
That's just how it be sometimes
Okay, I'm tapping to interact with anything over here
I am going this way nothing is happening
I'm going down nothing is happening
Going up down turn around
I'm dropping it's like it's hot
Nothing is happening
Come on
Oh
Maybe after I find the tapes I can go outside
I'm going down. I'm yelling timber
Hold on I'm like too far away
All right, now I can't see you guys. Where are you?
Oh, she blows
Ah
Okay, hold on somebody quickly look up how to run in
Mr. Hopps play
House
Controls
I don't think I can run
Any are you okay? Are you okay? I don't think I can run
They showed the controls when you started. Yeah, but did I look at them? No
Okay
Have did I fuck myself like what I can't like because you you generally you can't clear the train you can't
You
I'm on I'm on controller because if I do oh
Okay, if I do it on here
I can run are you serious then why can't I run on the controller?
Okay, it looks like I'm just gonna play it some keyboard then you're gonna hear my tippy taps
Well, it's shift on my keyboard, but I don't know what of the yeah, I think it's on controller. There's no run
Please go away
Fuck it
Oh, okay, so that works out is there anything else I need to grab over here
Are you serious
I have to
That was not clear that I have to
Have mercy will travel away is mercy a chat or my or you guys just saying mercy
Okay, that's a lot easier that I can freaking run
I can't do anything with that though
See behind me. It's fine
I'm motherfucking fast with it mom
Mother
Mama
Oh, there's another tape recorder
Jenna Ruby and I went to see Esther yesterday Ruby always loved seeing her grandmother. No, no, she calls her
She's not been doing so well in recent months. She went around the other weekend. I can't
Hear the tape over your fucking
dumb ass music. Um
We had to shake her to snap out of it and then she was just fine like nothing had happened
She has dementia god knows how long she's been doing that for we booked her for a doctor's appointment
I'm supposed to be recording ideas for new novel
Yeah, oh, why do I feel like there's a tape in the bedroom?
But I didn't see it there has to be a tape in here
It would not make sense if there was not a tape in here
I love sheepie cotton book
Hi, mercy
Why would there be a tape in the bedroom? Hey
Wait, wait, hold on. Let me get let me get real close
Hey, I want to make a movie
I
Someone open the blinds like go open the curtains
You know what that sound is not as footsteps this is ass clapping
Uh, it's I'm going
Jesus Christ
Have his has his eyes gotten creepier
Mr. Hopps kind of thick damn
My ass cheeks are clapping so loud it's alerting the guards
Oh, well shit, let me just eat
I'm waiting for him to just like walk forward
Can I like go in these rooms? No, okay, anything in here? No
It's coming closer. It's RT to run it. It's not working. Oh
Oh
Our art right trigger is to quit
This doesn't work
I'm like holding that I'm doing I'm pressing every button trying to run on controller
Yeah
I just don't know why it doesn't want to work in controller
He's coming back
Press the quit button to run all time for my work. You're right. Let me try that. Give me a second after this though
Anything over here? No
Yep
Jenna and I stopped to see Esther again today. The place was so filthy. Wait, is this David? Is this the husband?
I'm not sure how it would have
Got her so bad so quickly Esther doesn't seem to be keeping herself clean either and it's almost like she didn't recognize us
Her appointment is tomorrow. Jenna is worried that she might have to go into care. I'll keep this documented
I hope ruby doesn't have to see her like this
Please
I'm stuck in this
Ah, yes
Ah, we love to see it
For the love of christ, please let me out of this
Ah
Guys i'm not having a good time
Oh my god
It's free on steam
I
Got please I want to play the game. I want to know what happens
But I also don't want to have to go through stuff again. Oh my god
I'm like, is it me? Am I just stupid like
Maybe I am holding the button. I've held it. I've held it
I'm holding it
What is happening
Okay, I game whatever
Let's go for the second tape
Why is this game being so mean to you? I don't know it's already I don't know
Is he gone
No, that's because I tabbed out like a bitch this game hates bunnies this game is
You know, it's very discriminatory
Just because my estranged uncle just looks a little different doesn't mean
Oh
He isn't deserving of love and affection
Yep, oh fuck it
Ha ha bitch a two bitch
I
If I do this
I don't know. Well, it doesn't matter anymore. I was gonna like trigger the toy
Okay, there's nothing upstairs it doesn't really matter if I do that
It's laying on everything
Oh see now it's working now it's working
Why is he quiet
Is he in my room
What
Why does he sound like he's over here? Why is there no tape in my room?
I bet if I set the the bear off he would like come running in my room
Okay, let me just yep running start
I don't hear him on this floor
Yeah
Oh
If I stand from the hole will he get me
All right, I need to go
For all the tapes
There wasn't any over here, but again my game bugged out so who knows
I need a Christmas tree
Then a Honda lightning Mcsheebie
That's fine
I offer you an accord I offer you an accord I usually can do um her voice
Wait, you know what this calls for actually no I can't
Because
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do
Where the fuck are these tapes
I feel like they're just randomly around the house from places I've already been
I did not expect if he's supposed to change like that that was good. Thank you
Yeah, I offer you an accord it's just a Honda accord she be type R
I did it nothing happened now what?
I have to restart the game
I'm plug-and-replug. Oh honda type R. Oh
No, no cars, okay
Leave me alone
I
Sir one in here
Guys, I think the game's bugged
Oh
I set up for a split second
Caught me again
Oh, I almost landed in the car
Wondering how set three AM's simulator literally
Please
I
Why is it back here
As I'm recording this ashes in the hospital her neighbors called the police in the early hours of the morning because I'm stretching
Oh
Stretching her mother out because they could hear his screaming. She'll be there for a few days
We told ruby that she had a fall and she's okay. We're basing on diagnosis. She's crazy
Yeah, I'm trying to find the damn tapes
Walking back and forth around this house like a motherfucker
You
Touching what what?
Is there any tapes in here?
We took ruby to the hospital to see her nana her banana
It's not stupid ester made a soft toy for her could mr. Hope a small rabbit ester always knitted her clothes and toys
Ruby was thankful, but I must admit this toy does have a look to it
Something quite unsettling
That's why we really yeah, my uncle he's coming to you know
Take care of the house
Take care of everything
Banana oh
Yeah, see that's what I totally meant to say
I hate when my dead grandma haunts my toys you're wrong. No
I have to toot
Toot accomplished, you know what this calls for
An uncrossable
Like the ASMR you guys didn't even hear it. How can you?
Peanut butter and strawberry jam
No, I didn't pull an emmy
Um
If you don't know what uncrossable is it's essentially
Two slices of white bread. It's a PB and J
Just cut off the corners and seal them and it's a circle
Booby is eyeing my uncrossable
You can't have any
Just a wee snack
I
I've only had to waffle and uncrossable today. I should probably have something protein or veggie based
Are they better than just making one? Yes, the bread is so soft and
Definitely unhealthy for you
strawberry toaster's drool. I haven't had toaster's drool since I was
Unnugget
We already said this
Since I was a wee nugget stop it stop it
Bust it down Tatiana bust it down bust it down thought the other buses that
Looks like I like spilled milk everywhere
Looks like I superhero landed
Yeah
No, no, it's not that
That's fucked up. This is literally a fucking kid
Oh my god, his face is getting more fucked up
Can I leave now
Okay
His mouth is just open
Now he's coming closer I must ran for it
How does he teleport up the stairs so fast?
Oh
Booby I'm so sorry. I just scared you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh big man. I'm so sorry. I scared you
Give a timer before you die like Sonic
That got me again
Oh, I can go in through that way. Oh, that's so much easier
She would talk to us like that
Hey, uh, welcome to your first day on the job. Uh, thanks for taking it, you know
There was a lot of people that didn't want to take this job
Hello
The fuck
How do you know it was me that picked up
All right for the 50th time, let's try my parents bedroom
All right
Sorry, uh-huh mark. Hello
Hello
All right, this is
I made it. I made it. I made it. I made it. Fuck. Fuck him. Fuck him. Fuck him. Fuck him
Okay, there must be one up here now
Yes, the little girl is Ruby
Don't look in the drawers. Oh, I almost went for it
This is literally walking simulator
Back from the bar fitting named purgatory. That's funny bar called purgatory. Oh, thank god
We just had a call as they're passed away in her sleep
The doctors couldn't give us diagnosis and even said the sudden passing is bizarre
You'll have to tell Ruby when she oh a demon did it a demon did it. Oh a demon did it
Oh, sorry boomie
I realized I didn't put my
wrist rest back and I'm like, why is my wrist hurt because my on the edge of my
Bad desk
It was mr. Hopps
He was hopping
I don't like that noise that doll made
Okay, is there one over here
There has to be one in my room. Okay, it must be in my parents room then
Yeah
All right, don't forget I have no sense of direction
What up she be how is everyone um poorly navigating a game
And I have to sneeze again
Boom boom
The sound of my ass cheeks is alerting the guards so I can't do a snake voice though
Oh, you see that oh fuck
I sleep I was knocked out
Fainted oh jump scare. Oh, whatever
Hmm, let me check this one more time. Okay
I
September 22nd Ruby hasn't been on her best behavior since the news
We got to take her slingshot away because she won't stop firing pellets at the toy rabbit
She said it protects her from it. It's just a toy
We've had to lock the slingshot away since ruby kept finding it jenna keeps the key under a houseplant in the hallway. I think
Why is her father just record tapes?
Like who does that in this day and age? Is that a house plate in the hallway?
Is this a house plate in the hallway? There's a lot of houseplants in the hallway
Hmm
Yo, oh, I'm not gonna make it. I made it
Wait
Check
Which hallway?
Which houseplant be more specific? How are you ever gonna remember?
Right in funny noises me
Hello
I'm literally pressing everything. Oh my god. I got it
Okay, but then now where
is
Like where is it stored? He didn't say where it was stored. Yeah journal pages would make more sense
Fuck fuck
I'm assuming it's back in their bedroom
Go go. Oh fuck. Oh fuck. I ran out of shit
Okay, but there's a fucking safe in here
Huh
Oh, April 18th
Big brain what? Hello
I press the wrong button
Please oh wait, they're British. Maybe it might go in the opposite direction
Okay, well
Ah
British time British is not the proper way
That's dumb. Oh, can I shoot him?
Wait, how do I shoot?
I fucked up the controls. I had to use the other thing I had to use
Oh
Okay, let's go
Fuck you
I got this this is where the game begins
In the early version of the game it was a gun
She just gets a fucking gun
Oh, where is he where is he come here, bitch
I'm ready for you. It's hard to these controls
Oh
This is very tense
What I don't understand about this game is that
I don't know how the how the
Game mechanic works because you know like a 3d game like you know
There can be rooms like stacked on each other that you go through and that's how you progress like um
But like I'm wondering why can I hear the monster right here?
Is there like technically another part of this?
Where he's on the other side
like I don't
Is another room that just does it oh
It's so fucking tense
You
Objective kill mr. Hopps she got the Glock. Yeah, I mean it's probably the basement
I have a sneeze again
Well now I know he does not gonna come so I don't really care
Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Oh, what I couldn't leave
All right
I
Need a jump shot. Oh, maybe maybe I do need a jump shot. Yeah
Yeah
Go for his ankles
I don't know I think I'm too short
I think I'm too short
Because I can't go back up
Is my game bugging again
Oh
Am I hmm, maybe
Okay, I'll I'll I'll test y'all's theory
So you see the little red because there's a cool you can't see it past me because my head is fucking huge
But there's a cool down
Um meter
I
Can't
I didn't do anything different that time
I didn't do anything different
All I did was
Do I have to like start up here and then I don't
Might get make sense
Can I call for help? Nope. Oh, what the fuck are the controls again?
Oh
Why is it saying that
Weird I don't know why it's acting like I can do something. Can I leave now?
No, I don't want to give my nana a big kiss
It's time to kill nana
Fuck you nana. Oh
Fuck you
Fuck you fuck
Nope, I'm good
Oh god
Oh
Okay
What police stay where you are
What the fuck
I
It seems like you guys are just as confused as me how I escaped when they grabbed me
That doesn't make any sense. Can I replay that?
I'm replaying that
I can't go any faster
I
Can't even like get out of this
They don't even explain
Why the police were there shoot the hand what if you fought instead of escaping okay, let's try it
But it says to run though
I
Yeah, I don't I don't think that works
Maybe your neighbor called them. Oh, that makes sense
You shift to that's what I've been using shift to spread
I read yours like chef that's right
I
Didn't notice that three times that I did that. Okay, let's try to outrun the thingy my barber
It's weird the first time
That I got put in the situation the hand didn't spawn for a really long time
And that was the only reason I was caught because I thought I could turn around and shoot at it
And that's why I paused for a bit the first time
So I don't know
The game obviously is bucky, but it's like a you know, it's like just an indie game
I'll try one more time. I'm gonna make it
It's the same ending
Was it my grandma? Was she possessed? I don't
Okay
All right
Nice
Anything past the door, I don't think so. Well, this game is what hold on. Let me see how old it is
It came out in 2019
This thing is very positive
Achievements are broken somebody said oh someone else said you get capped like it is the same ending
And then it makes zero sense
Yes
Thumbs up haha British funny. Okay, so it seems like it's supposed to be like that
Thought there was an ending where you burned down the house
What
The other ending is a secret ending they made a prequel. Yeah, I know there's a second one
I'm like I'm playing the free one though
What's this there's an ending where I burned down the house, what do you well now I'm looking up a walk through
Don't mind if I do
I
Plus collect the first tape then you go back to the kitchen and you get lighter fluid
After you collected all the tapes find the slingshot then shoot
Mr. Hop six times go left shoot a pot on the side table that is near you and you get a box of matches
You see some pieces of paper once you're staying on the piece of paper press e or z to set them on fire
That is so elaborate for no reason and I like spammed everything in the kitchen after I got the first tape
I didn't see any of the lighter fluid
I
Yeah, people said that it also wouldn't let them light the paper. Okay. Well, I'm not gonna I'm not gonna bother playing through all that
Got the arson, but yeah ending those already. Yeah, it seems like you have to I'd have to like start
I'm like, I don't feel like doing all that. I don't feel like doing all that
Oh
Hold on let me move over a bit and we can chat a bit
That's a little wee cheeky chat in it
It's juice. Oh, no, it's not Tuesday. Tuesday's yesterday and I didn't even say it's juicy in it
dumb
Let me close the game out
Oh white woman jump scare I've been flashbaked
My eyes
There we go
Oh man
So
What do you think of my game skills? Okay, so I've been really uh validated the past few days playing uh
Playing these games that have bugs in them because then I'm like, oh, is it me? Is it me?
It's not me. Sometimes the game is bugged and that makes me feel a lot better
I was positively glowing. She'd be flash bomb
Oh god white woman flashbang again
Oh
It's not the flashbang I wanted
My goodness
Yeah, see, you know, I I'm a I'm a gamer. What are we playing? Where's my schedule? Hold on
Titty's flying around. Oh this stinger is so long
Uh
Oh
We get class of oh nine tomorrow. I forgot what I put on my schedule. It happens often. We got class of oh nine tomorrow, baby
Oh, yeah, you guys are on you guys are on my face
Oh my god, you're on top of me. How did this happen? Oh, okay
I feel like she is a character from class of oh nine
Uh, we have one of my friends played it on stream. Um
nyaru
So i'm like, oh my god, I have to play this because she played it and I was like, that looks so fucking funny
I'm the dumb is all with
Mods ban this guy who's saying he's a dumb. I don't ban. Well, don't ban. I'm just time him out get fucked get fucked
Get conked
The mods are slow in the draw
My mods are failing me
All right
I feel like I feel like mod was just like this is like sipping a drink. It was like, oh, oh mistress. I'm so sorry
I'm the alpha dome
So
There can only be one um this this chat isn't big enough for two
I've gone drunk with power
That's my new laugh you guys like it even working on it
Yes
That way my mouth moves when I do it
So based
Stop what do you mean stop? It's great or I could be like
I could be like
It's not like a one piece character
Hi for one welcome our goofy dummy overload as you should oh someone
Mentioned the game called overlord. I've never heard of it, but um
I'm I'll I'll try it. I saw the premise
Recently because I googled it and I was like, oh, okay. This actually sounds pretty cool. So I might try to play it
Hi
Vehicle stream, isn't it just dungeon keeper? I don't know. I don't know bro
My dad wants me to play mist
Sorry, I'm like scratching my face and my eyes are like, oh
Nope, not that's what I want. I want to make my eyes bigger
It's actually like peakman I never played peak bed
This is a great game. I heard it has puzzles
Yeah, my dad said I should play mist my dad. Um, I remember he'd play like a lot of like
PlayStation I remember just watching him play like crisis
And he also had like the orange box with like um half life and stuff
I
Must be okay because it's chilly. Yeah. Yeah, my dad's a major gamer
Miss scared you it just looks like a
We're like a just a 3d puzzle game. How could that scare you?
Why are you scared child?
I'm so easy to know what we're gonna do
We're gonna read in me in a few and she's gonna wake you up by playing poppy's playtime chapter two
I don't know why she's playing chapter two and not chapter one, but
She's like forget
Huggy wuggy
We going straight for mommy
I'm gonna take the fatist of naps
Because I'm so freaking tired
But we'll chat we'll chat till she comes on. Let me see
Yeah, maybe she already played chapter one
Well, I like replaying games like I'm I'm playing like call the lamb and vampire the masquerade with you guys and I've already played it
But what was I doing? I was checking if emu was up yet
That she let she
Okay, she is cool
Let's do a cheeky raid then have a good rest of your night
Give emu my love I'll read in with you guys and say hi before I pass the fuck out. She just started. Yes. Yes. Yes, perfect
Perfect. She's right on time. Don't you love how punctual we all are? Oh, we're so good. Let me even scream earlier sometimes
That's really good
Very good. Okay
Bye
Why do you guys still smell stinky?
You